rennes est plus forte que l'amour dans
notre société jean messia avec tout ce
qu'on entend j'aimerais pas l'avis de
jean-claude parce que jean coutton
humaniste non mais c'est vrai qu'un
humaniste on le voit dans les films on
voit dans tout ce que tu fais ouais en
fait tout ce que j'aime chez toi la côte
c'est que tu fais ton truc moi je t'ai
jamais entendu mal parler de quelqu'un
je t'ai jamais entendu dénigrer quelque
chose tu fais ta vie ça a été ton truc
depuis tout petit plus depuis que tu vas
là depuis que tu es connu et ça c'est ça
que j'aime chez toi c'est que tu traces
qui trace son chemin tu t'occupes pas
des autres et qu'à jamais critiquer tel
ou tel personne je fais de mon mieux
mais c'est ça que j'aime chez toi dressé
mais c'est quoi c'est un fléau d'objets
tu te dis que moi je moi je fais mon
truc
j'aime pas être dans la haine dans
lequel a critical eux mais si on veut
chercher la perfection il faut quand
même ne pas juger c'est ça ouais non
c'est pas on sait pas et c'est de cette
intersection jeunes un copain qui émane
et puisqu'on parle de perfection chacun
nous conte de neige
ils ont la même dimension un que ce soit
- s'accroche c'est des gros flocons mais
chaque flocon de neige ont la même
dimanche les paroles des three lions
maniement sion bat donc c'est la seule
chose le seul élément qui a une
perfection sur la paix il en parle à mon
copain et m'a dit oui mais tu sais il ya
ma mère qui m'a dit qu'il y ait de l'oil
c'est une fleur qui grandit sur des
détails si c'est la seule fleur qui peut
grandir à travers la neige
ah ouais je demande est-ce que je suis
une pour ça qu'après cinq à bord
c'est très important d'avoir des gens je
lui demande est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
peut être une aide aux animaux moi je
trouve donc on a la chance dans ce monde
de perfection fin sur la neige gelée sur
snoopy d'éclore que mais si tu parles de
la nhtsa c2c loin tu avais dit il
la lan était là on a même parlé de
l'amour n étaient plus fortes que les
remous dans notre société je crois que
la n1 la haine la haine ne sera pas
guéri avec l'a1
mais la haine se guérit avec l'amour non
mais c'est en temps ça c'est important
moi je crois que la question à poser
c'est pourquoi tant de haine
ça c'est parce que l'aisne temps a parlé
tout à l'heure il ya des haines tous les
jours il ya des explosions de haine de
violence de tension mais en même temps
envie on vit on vit dans un pays où on a
un état providence hyper généreux qui
paye la santé qui paye l'éducation ou
les transports sont pas très cher où il
ya tout un filet de social pour les
études pour l'installation avec tout un
tas de lois un état de droit qui protège
contre les inégalités les
discriminations moi c'est pas parfait
mais enfin bon on est mieux qu'ailleurs
et donc du coup la question est alors le
tout évidemment baigné d'une dans une
propagande de vivre ensemble etc
donc on devrait être dans un pays hyper
serein la question c'est pourquoi malgré
sa part que malgré ça et bien sûr notre
pays et dans le monde
je parle je parle en france parce que
bon c'est le pays que je connais le
mieux par définition mais
moi la question elle est là et je pense
que effectivement on a en france dont 10
ont des problèmes socio économiques
mises en action mais ce à quoi je crois
une solution peut-être une solution à un
raccourci pour guérir cette fin la haine
les idées discussions et tout ça
j'embrasse cas même dans les plateformes
pour ce sens là donc les grandes
plateformes et créer un symbole une
sorte de langage ou coup tout le monde
peut se comprendre
te retrouver ce qu'on est grâce à des
informations intellectuelle parce que tu
vas faire une opération du coeur sais
pas comment ça se passe tu as peur si tu
sais le processus de l'opération déjà à
l'aise donc une plateforme qui informe
les gens comment développer l'amour
qu'on a dans notre dans notre salon et
ça sera super programme une application
qui s'appelle application d'amour film
goûte on adore se tient juste c copyrigh
à la tv
[Rires]
sur l'international il a dit que la
haine et de la peur c'est vrai oui c'est
exact mais sachant qu'il faut travailler
sur la peur mais on annonce qui dit je
vous jure que c'est vrai regardez bien
tout ce qu'il a dit a réfléchi
extrêmement bien géré je n'ai et sa
survie rafler tout ce qui dit il ne rien
dépenser et eva rivas qui l'a dit c'est
vrai que la haine vient de la peur il a
tout à fait raison
non c'est la basse continue quand il dit
l'amour va guérir la l mine de rien jean
mais c'est à vous moi non mais là tout
le monde ne comprend pas l'amour
malheureusement c'est à dire que s'il
suffisait de combattre la haine par
l'amour dans ce cas là après toutes les
manifestations que nous avons eue après
les grands attentats où on voyait des
gens dire vous n'aurez pas ma haine ou
le voyez des gens très pacifique avec
des bougies des nounours des bisous
bisous normalement les attentats
auraient dû s'arrêter alors vous voyez
qui sont pas arrêtés parce que des gens
qui comprennent pas non plus en l'amour
il ya des gens qui créent des situations
de violence pour des situations
politiques
moi je pense qu'ils vont avec oh non non
c'est vrai ce qu'ils ont mais la grande
philosophie de la vie il ya la logique
il ya de grippe la grippe c'est quand
quelqu'un meurt
la colère c'est ça puis à la jalousie la
jalousie les gens sont jaloux à cette
envie et puis il ya la peur et puis à
l'amour c'est tout cette feeling
l'aviation ses contrôles et ses sept
tours en fasse un tour avec 7,7 milling
et ben c'est un peu la simple alors
c'est ce que vous dites la philosophie
de la vie ce que vous dites est très
beau mais le mais je crains que les
français ne comprennent pas exactement
ce que ça veut dire concrètement moi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui
concrètement notre pays en fait se
disloque en raison de la fracture
identitaire
[Rires]
[Musique]
de plus en plus des problèmes
économiques c'est très simple en fait si
vous prenez une cocotte et qu'à
l'intérieur
vous mettez des chrétiens des juifs des
musulmans dé tout ça vous ajoutez du
chômage de la misère économique 1 et que
vous mettez tout ça sur un feu
idéologique d'accord qui excite des
minorités d'expérience contre la
majorité
havas a fini par péter c'est les
explosions de violence en france avec
une chose comme ça si je mets un chiffre
devant vous qui s'appelle 7 points
quelque chose millions d'habitants sur
la terre il ya renoncé ni trop gras
milliards à des problèmes il ya une
quantité énorme qu'on ne peut plus gérer
le nombre de deux pions enfin de
commencer donc géré par l'énoncé des
choses est un jardin d'enfants avec
fronde mais 300 gosses ça va se battre
mais non mais je sais mathématiquement
14 12 am
jusqu'alors le mot fracture merci
bloodsport s'il revient